Speaker 1: I am going to show you right
now why later. Let's do it now. How Tucker
Carlson turns reality into conspiracy theory.
And this is a really great example. You know,
I've told you before. Very often right wing
talking points and or conspiracy theories start
with a kernel of truth. There's a kernel of truth
somewhere, even if it's sometimes sort of hard
to find. And it is fundamental. If you want to be
an informed consumer of political and news media,
think for yourself. Be able to to figure things
out for yourself, to understand the mechanism that
I'm going to show you here in this clip, Tucker
Carlson talks about the signing ceremony that took
place yesterday at the White House for the bill
that codifies gay marriage into law, even though
it doesn't really all it says is states have to
recognize gay marriages but doesn't actually say
states have to grant marriage licenses to gay or
lesbian couples. We talked about the bill earlier
in the week. I was invited to go to the White
House for this event just to show they literally
invited me the day before. I just couldn't make
it on that short notice because I had to be here
with all of you doing a show. Who do they think
I am? But in any case, they had this event and
Tucker Carlson starts talking about the event. But
look at how quickly he takes the kernel of truth
and expands it into an absurd conspiracy theory.
Speaker 2: It's pretty interesting when you think
about it. So this is a bill signing, affirming
the legality, legalizing once again gay marriage,
which most people support in this country.
Be people to get married if they love
each other. Yeah, they should. That's fine.
Speaker 1: Okay. So that is true. It was an event
to sign that bill. The bill is about affirming gay
marriages, even though it doesn't guarantee them.
But like the event happened, that's what the
bill is for so far. It's okay. Let's continue.
Speaker 2: Not that controversial a point at this
stage, but here's Joe Biden using that opportunity
to promote gender affirming care for kids. And
of course, that means the sexual mutilation
of children cutting their breasts or 15 year
olds sterilizing them for life with chemicals.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, we looked at the
numbers cutting off the breasts of 15 year olds.
Understand? They've already had to modify their
talking point on this. First they were talking
about cutting the breasts off of prepubescent
girls. Prepubescent girls don't really have
breasts to cut off. So then they started going
into, well, these are minors. Are they 18 or
17 and a half or 50? So they're just modifying
the exact figures to try to make it plausible.
But this really isn't happening. And there are,
of course, in a country of 331 million people,
you can find examples of everything, and often
for good reasons and different reasons that we
may not even know because of medical privacy in
particular cases. But he's expanding this into oh,
well, now this is celebrating the event
which was about affirming gay marriage,
is about celebrating double mastectomies
for gender affirming reasons on 15 year
old girls, which basically doesn't happen.
Speaker 2: That's what Boston Children's
Hospital in many other hospitals
have been doing. Puberty blockers
have fun with osteoporosis when you're 30.
Speaker 1: Okay. Now that I don't know about,
I don't know about any potential link between
puberty blockers and osteoporosis. Not really
the crux of this discussion, though.
Speaker 2: So why would Joe Biden be
promoting that apart from the fact certain
special interest groups want him to?
Speaker 1: Okay. So there is another
idea, which is part of the reason Biden
is promoting this stuff, which he isn't and
which barely ever happens, is that it's the
money. There are moneyed interests that want
the so-called mutilation of children. We're off
the deep end now into conspiracy world.
Speaker 2: Again, this was supposed to
be about gay marriage, and it was. But here
you have Joe Biden, president United States
purportedly pushing child sexual mutilation.
Speaker 1: Now, we are very off the deep end
from where we started here. And it's important
to understand how these things happen outside of
the media right now. Tucker, because this is
a for profit show, but outside of the media,
just among the population, sometimes reality
gets turned into a conspiracy theory,
sort of accidentally. It can happen when people
are trying to make sense of something that's
complicated or there are unfamiliar events. People
don't have all the information and they start
filling in gaps and they add interpretations or
they add assumptions or they assume the worst and
put that in there. And that can really distort
your picture of what happened. Sandy Hook is a
great example of that. You can often also get
into conspiracy ville when people are looking
to explain events that are difficult to understand
or that go against their beliefs or that point to
a much more dangerous and unpredictable world
than people would like to believe we have. So
you fill it in with a conspiracy to say there
wasn't randomness. It wasn't. It was planned.
That's not what Tucker is doing. Tucker is doing
a show where he is deliberately taking something
completely benign and uncontroversial, an event
signing this affirm affirmation of gay marriage
bill and turning it into a conspiracy theory,
which is the type of thing his audience is already
expecting to hear. Biden Affirming Gay Marriage.
There's got to be more to that. There must be evil
lurking somewhere. And when you hear something
like this, there are really simple steps you
can take to evaluate it. And this may be our next
white paper, quite frankly. Examine the evidence,
look at the evidence that exists and consider,
is this evidence credible and reliable? Is it
based in fact, is it speculation? Is it hearsay
start there? Are there alternative explanations
that are not nefarious based on the credible
evidence that we have? Look at the sources.
Who's presenting the conspiracy theory. Do they
have a motive to present a conspiracy theory
rather than what is suggested by the facts that
we actually know for sure? Check for confirmation
bias. Is the person giving you the theory or are
you looking for evidence that supports a certain
conclusion already and ignoring evidence that
contradicts it? Confirmation bias. We've talked
about that. Look for independent verification.
Check to see has the conspiracy theory been
ident independently verified by others? Have other
people or organizations looked at the evidence and
come to the same conclusions? Or are there other
conclusions that folks have come to? And lastly,
the always think critically, does it pass the
sniff test? Does it make any sense? Is it logical
and consistent with other things that I know
about the world, aside from being supported by
the evidence? That's the framework. And it might
make for a great white paper. And by the way,
more than 3000 people have now downloaded the
free guide to having political arguments with
people. David Pakman dot com slash
guide. It's genuinely free. It's
a free guide. It's available. Download
it at David Pakman dot com slash guide.
Our sponsor Real Paper makes toilet paper
100% from bamboo, never from trees, meaning no
deforestation. Sustainability and climate change
can be a tricky topic for people of all ages. It
can be particularly challenging to talk about with
kids and Real Paper recently launched the Little
Lemurs Box, a 24 pack of their bamboo toilet
paper with a beautifully illustrated kids book
that tells an exciting story of sustainability.
The box is designed to spark creativity in kids,
create an opportunity to talk about deforestation,
plastic pollution in a way that's light and easy.
And with the holidays here, the book makes a great
gift for a little one on your list. Real papers,
little lemurs, box, and all of the other
products are available in easy hassle free
subscriptions or just simple one time purchases
on their website. All orders are conveniently
delivered to your door with free shipping. And
this is the best part. 100% recyclable plastic
free packaging. Go to real paper dot com, slash
lima and sign up for a subscription using code
pacman at checkout to get 30% off your first
order and free shipping. The link is down below.